-We are in the Doombox.
Our next three songs
will decide
tonight's champions.
It's time for
Slay It, Don't Spray it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I know the words
are new this way ♪
-Now, here's how this works.
Players from each team
will take turns
singing well known songs,
karaoke style.
They'll have the lyrics
in front of them,
but when the music drops out,
they'll have to finish
the line from memory
If they don't get the lyrics
exactly right,
the microphones in front of them
will spray water in their face.
But if they can slay it and sing
all of the words perfectly,
then their opponents
get drenched instead.
Each song
is worth 50,000 points,
so it's still anyone's game.
Alright, Halle, Simu,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Poker Face," Lady Gaga.
Now you have to decide
who's going to sing this one.
Do you know it?
Who knows "Poker Face."
-I think you should sing it.
-I will do it, Jimmy.
-You're going to go?
Alright.
-Okay, whenever you're ready,
please begin.
♪♪
Are you getting nervous?
-Yeah.
♪♪
-I didn't even --
♪ I'll show him what I've got ♪
-[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
-I don't even know the words.
-I'm so sorry.
You are so relieved right now,
Chloe.
-Oh, my God.
That is 50,000 points
for Adam and Chloe right there.
-Oh, we're so far down.
Let's see that
in slow motion, please.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Okay, Chloe and Adam,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song you get.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheering ]
-"No Scrubs."
-Okay, okay, I got it.
I got it, I got it, okay.
-Alright, here we go.
Whenever you're ready.
-Give it to me.
♪♪
♪ Trying to holla at me ♪
-Yes!
-[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
-Sorry, sis.
-Do you want a towel?
I mean, Halle, I'm sorry.
Who knew the Little Mermaid
was going
to get so wet tonight.
I had no idea.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is 50,000 points
for your team.
Can we see that once again,
one more time?
That's a good one.
-[ Slow-motion screaming ]
Wow.
You knew it was coming.
Oh, my gosh.
-Oh. Oh, my gosh.
-Guys, it's time
for the final round,
and this time we're really
opening up the floodgates.
Watch your heads, because we got
the big mics coming in.
-The bigger, the better.
It's time to get wetter.
-Oh, my.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, We have to get this.
-Alright, now, all four of you
are going to take turns singing,
so pay attention
to your screens, okay?
You'll switch off line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail the lyrics
or you and your partner
will get drenched.
And this round
is worth 200,000 points.
So whoever wins, wins --
-Oh, my God.
-Wins the whole thing.
Let's see what
our final song is.
[ Cheering ]
"I Wanna Dance With Somebody"
by Whitney Houston.
-Halle, you're going to be
starting us off.
Whenever we're ready,
here we go.
-We got this.
We got this.
♪♪
-Whoo!
-Simu, you're up next.
♪♪
Halle.
Chloe.
♪♪
Simu.
-♪ With somebody who loves me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo, whoo, whoo!
-[ Slow-motion screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, so we have a winner.
Halle and Simu,
you are tonight's
"That's My Jam" champions.
Get out here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You get your own boombox.
-I get my own
-Yeah.
Come on out here.
You're the winners.
Come on out, guys.
Come on out here.
You're mad here
or are your mad at your sister?
Come on.